Notice that this algorithm does n
over 2 additions at this statement.
Then at this statement,
it does n over 2 minus 1 additions.
And finally, the add scan operates
on a problem that's half the size.
So what does that mean?
Basically, the recurrence for
the total work is this.
So the work is linear in n.
Before moving on to the span,
let me make a quick remark.
I hid a constant in here.
What's the constant?
As it happens, the constant is about 2.
Now that 2 is counting
only addition operations.
Now this factor of two
is pretty interesting.
Think about what that means for
a second.
The purely sequential algorithm
only has a constant of about 1.
So evidently our parallel
algorithm does twice the work.
Now wearing your theory hat,
that's not a big deal.
But it does raise an interesting and
more general question.
Will you, in general,
need to pay some sort of price
in order to get parallelism?
Okay, Voodak, enough with
the distractions, what about the span?
Now the first observation
is the recursive call,
which always operates on
a sub-problem of half the size.
So you'd naturally expect
about O (log n) levels.
All the other operations
are data parallel.
That means you can implement
them using parallel fours,
which will also have logarithmic span.
Putting that together, here's what
the recurrence might look like.
If you solve the recurrence
you will get O(log^2n).
Again the master theorem makes
solving it quick and easy.
Alternatively, you should be
able to see the log squared and
behavior intuitively.
There's login span from the statements
within this function, and
that's repeated log in times.